[Music]
Hollywood loves scaring audiences and
based on the numbers alone movie fans
can't get enough a lot can be done to
produce a truly great fright some movies
rely on endless blood and gore others
meanwhile prefer a more subtle
atmospheric [ __ ] here are six
techniques used to terrify audiences
[Music]
horror sound is about more than just a
creaky door or Wilhelm scream it's about
finding the exact right sound to make
you just the right level of squeamish
sound designers have found certain foods
can mimic the sounds they want this is
where fully objects come in handy a few
sticks of celery can make for a good
bone crack squishing a pepper sounds a
lot like a skull crush and raw meat
sounds exactly like guts consideration
for sound can also make zombies even
scarier than they already are
zombies that becomes so popular in
mainstream movie culture and television
culture that we've got this huge history
of zombie movies to kind of call upon I
really like the stuff that air is closer
to what reality would be or maybe more
of the gory zombies that are more
guttural and Flemmi and kind of
grotesque because I think those are the
things that scare people a little bit
more than the zombie movies of old
[Music]
makeup is a vital part of any scary
character think about anyone from Freddy
Krueger to the whites and White Walkers
on Game of Thrones prosthetics are
typically made first by doing a life
cast of an actor to get their face and
body measurements accurate actors go
under layers and layers of makeup in
order to portray an undead life form
scary prosthetics aren't just for horror
movies they're useful for any scene that
calls for blood and gore the best way to
make them cringe-worthy is to aim for
realism
in black-and-white movies like psycho
chocolate syrup was reputedly used as a
substitute for blood today Hollywood
uses a combination of corn syrup and
food coloring to create a bloody mess
but it's not just about quality it's
about quantity like with foley food can
be used to create disgustingly realistic
guts not everything can be done
practically especially if you're making
a monster movie where the monster has to
be created from scratch in Jurassic
world fallen Kingdom the Indo Raptor a
dinosaur that never actually existed was
created using CGI CGI gave them freedom
to infuse the character with influences
from horror movies of the past the Indo
Raptor has some similar mannerisms to
Nosferatu CGI was also successfully used
an alien covenant to account for the
Xenomorphs otherworldly and
ever-changing nature one major challenge
of CGI creations the actors acting
alongside them can't see them all on set
this is where animatronics can save the
day
on the set of fallen Kingdom the crew
built a moving into Raptor arm and head
that way the actors could have more
genuine reactions to it and the screams
would be more authentic animatronics can
also just be plain frightening for the
infamous scene in the matrix where a
giant insect is placed inside neo it
wasn't CGI but an uncanny animatronic
[Music]
if you want to act in a horror movie
prepare to get physical and Annabel
creation they swung a character on wires
into a mirror the wires of course are
invisible in the final product but it
helps you believe that the supernatural
may be real plus a scary stunt can
elicit perhaps the biggest screams
[Music]
[Music]
you